YUFEI ZHAO: Today we want
to look at the sum product
problem.
So for the past
few lectures, we've
been discussing the
structure of sets
under the addition operation.
Today we're going to throw
in one extra operation, so
multiplication,
and understand how
sets behave under both
addition and multiplication.
And the basic problem here
is, can it be the case that A
plus A, A times A,
which is, analogously,
the set of all pairwise
products of elements from A--
can these two sets be
simultaneously small,
that is, the same
for some single A?
Can we have it so that
A plus A and A times A
are simultaneously small?
For example, it's easy to
make one of them small.
We've seen examples where if
you take A to be an arithmetic
progression, then A plus
A is more or less as
small as it gets.
But for such an example, you
see A times A is pretty large.
It's actually not so clear
how to prove how large it
Is.
And there are some
very nice proofs.
And this problem has actually
been more or less pinned down.
But the short version is
that A times A has size close
to its maximum possible.
So it turns out the size of A
times A is almost quadratic.
So this number is actually
now known fairly precisely.
So this problem of determining
the size of A times
A for the interval 1 through
N is known as the Erdos
multiplication table problem.
So if you take an N by
N multiplication table,
how many numbers do
you see in the table?
So that turns out to be
sub-quadratic, but not too
sub-quadratic.
So this problem has been more
or less solved by Kevin Ford.
And we now know a fairly
precise expression,
but I don't want
to focus on that.
That's not the topic
of today's lecture.
This is just an example.
Alternatively, you
can take A times A
to be quite small by taking A
to be a geometric progression.
Then it's not too hard
to convince yourself
that A plus A must be
fairly large in that case.
And the geometric
progression doesn't
have so much additive structure,
so A plus A will be large.
So can you make A plus A and A
times A simultaneously small?
So there's this conjecture
that the answer is no.
And this is a famous
conjecture in this area, known
as the Erdos similarity
conjecture on the sum product
problem, which states
that for all finite sets
of real numbers, either
A plus A or A times A
has to be close
to quadratic size.
So that's the conjecture.
It's still very much open.
Today I want to show
you some progress
towards this conjecture
via some partial results.
And it will use a nice
combination of tools
from graph theory and
incidence geometry,
so it nicely ties in
together many of the things
that we've seen in
this course so far.
So Erdos and Szemeredi
proved some bound,
which is like 1 plus
c for some constant c.
Today we'll show some bounds
for somewhat better c's.
So you'll see.
The first tool that
I want to introduce
is a result from graph theory
known as the "crossing number
inequality."
So you know that
planar graphs are
graphs where you can
draw on the planes
so that the edges do not cross.
And there are some famous
examples of non-planar graphs,
like K5 and K 3, 3.
But you can ask a more
quantitative question.
If I give you a graph,
how many crossings
must you have in every
drawing of this graph?
And the crossing
number inequality
provides some estimate
for such a quantity.
So given the graph G, denoted
by cr, so crossing of G,
to be the minimum number
of crossings in a planar
drawing of G. There
is a bit of subtlety
here, where by a planar drawing,
do I mean using line segments
or do I mean using curves?
It's actually not clear how
it affects this quantity here.
That's a very subtle issue.
So for planar graphs,
there's a famous result
that more or less says
if a planar graph can
be drawn using
continuous curves,
then it can be drawn
using straight lines.
But the minimum
number of crossings,
the two different
ways of drawings,
they might end up with
different crossing numbers.
But for the purpose
of today's lecture,
we'll use a more general notion,
although it doesn't actually
matter for today
which one we'll use--
so planar drawing using curves.
Draw the graph where edges
are continuous curves.
How many crossings do you get?
The crossing is a pair
of edges that cross.
You can ask-- it's just a
cross over point that can--
it doesn't matter.
So there are many
different subtle ways
of defining these things.
They won't really come
up for today's lecture.
The crossing number
inequality is a result
from the '80s, which give
you a lower-bound estimate
on the number of crossings.
If G is a graph
with enough edges--
the number of edges
is, let's say,
at least four times the
number of vertices--
then the number of crossings
of every drawing of G
is at least the
number of edges cubed
divided by the number
of vertices squared.
And there's an extra constant
factor, which is some constant.
So the constant does
not depend on the graph.
In particular, if it
has a lot of edges,
then every drawing of G must
have a lot of crossings.
So the crossing
number inequality
was proved by two separate
independent works,
one by Ajtai, Chvatal,
Newborn, Szemeredi and the
other by Tom Leighton,
our very own Tom Leighton.
So let me first give you some
consequences of this theorem,
just for illustration.
So if you have an n-vertex
graph with a quadratic number
of edges, then how many
crossings must you have?
You plug in these
parameters into the theorem.
See that it has necessarily
n to the 4th crossings.
But if you just draw the
graph in some arbitrary way,
you have at most n
to the 4 crossings,
because a crossing
involves four points.
So when you have a
quadratic number of edges,
you must get basically the
maximum number of crossings.
The leading constant term factor
is an interesting problem,
which we're not
going to get into.
Let's prove the crossing
number inequality.
First, the base case of the
crossing number inequalities
is when you can draw a
graph with no crossings.
And those are planar graphs.
So for every connected
planar graph,
if it has at least one cycle--
and you'll see why in a second,
why I say this--
if with at least one cycle,
so that's not a tree,
we must have that 3
times the number of faces
is at most 2 times
the number of edges.
So here, we're going
to use the key tool
being Euler's
formula, which we all
know as the number of vertices
minus the number of edges
plus the number of
faces equals to 2.
We're here for face, because
I draw a planar graph,
and so I count the faces.
Here there are two faces, outer
face, inner face, count edges
and vertices, so you have
Euler's formula up there.
And plug in Euler's
formula for a planar graph
with at least one cycle, so
we can obtain this consequence
over here, because every
face is adjacent to at least
three edges.
If you go around
the face, you see
these three edges, and every
edge is counted exactly twice,
is adjacent to
exactly two faces.
So you do the double counting,
you get that inequality up
there.
So plugging these two into Euler
gets you that inequality up
there.
Plugging these two into Euler,
we get that the number of edges
is almost 3 times the
number of vertices minus 6.
So for this leaves
that inequality,
but plug it into Euler, plug in
this into Euler, you get this.
So we have that
the number of edges
is at most 3 times the number
of vertices for every graph G.
So here, we require
that the graph is planar
and has at least one cycle, but
even if we drop the condition
that it has at least
one cycle but just
require that it's planar,
every planar graph G
satisfies this
inequality over here.
So in other words,
you might have
heard before, in a planar graph,
the average degree of a vertex
is almost 6.
So in particular, the
crossing number of a graph G
is positive if the
number of edges
exceeds 3 times the
number of vertices.
It's not planar, so
it has at least one
crossing every drawing.
And by deleting an edge
from each crossing,
we get a planar graph.
You draw the graph.
You have some crossings.
You get rid of an edge
associated with each drawing.
Then you get a planar graph.
If you look at this
inequality and you
account for the number of
edges that you deleted,
we obtain then the
inequality that the number
of edges minus the
number of crossings
is at least 3 times
the number of vertices.
So we obtain the
inequality that the lower
bounds in number of crossings
as the number of edges
minus 3 times the number
of vertices, this one.
So that's some lower bound
on the crossing number.
It's not quite the bound
that we have over there.
And in fact, if you take a
graph with a quadratic number
of edges, this bound
here only gives you
quadratic lower bound on
the crossing number, some
lower bound.
But it's not a
great lower bound.
And we would like to do better.
So here's a trick that
is a very nice trick,
where we're going to use
this inequality to upgrade it
to a much better
inequality, bootstrap it
to a much tighter inequality.
So this involves the use of
the probabilistic method.
Let me denote by p some
number between 0 and 1,
to be decided later.
And starting with
a graph G, let's
let G prime, with vertices
and edges being V prime and E
prime, be obtained from G
by randomly deleting some
of the vertices,
or rather randomly
keeping each vertex
with probability p,
independently for each
of these vertices.
So you have some graph G.
I keep each vertex
with probability p.
And I delete the
remaining vertices.
And I get a smaller graph.
I get some induced subgraph.
And I would like
to know what can we
say about the crossing number of
the smaller graph in comparison
to the crossing number
of the original graph?
For the smaller graph, because
it's still a planar graph
so G prime--
so it's still a graph.
It's not a planar graph,
but it's still a graph,
so G prime still satisfies
this inequality up here.
So G prime still satisfies
that the number of crossings
in every drawing of
G prime is at least
the number of edges of G
prime minus 3 times the number
of vertices of G prime.
But note that G prime
is a random graph.
G was fixed, given.
G prime is a random graph.
So let's evaluate
the expectation
of both quantities, left-hand
side and right-hand side.
If this inequality is
true for every G prime,
the same inequality must
be true in expectation.
Now what do we know about
all the expectations of each
of these quantities?
The number of vertices
in expectation--
that's pretty easy.
So this one here is p times the
original number of vertices.
The number of edges
is also pretty easy.
Each edge is kept if
both endpoints are kept.
So this expectation on the
number of edges remaining
is also pretty
easy to determine.
The crossing number
of the new graph--
that I have to be a little
bit more careful of,
because when you look
at the smaller graph,
maybe there's a
different way to draw it
that's not just deleting
the sum of the vertices
from the original graph.
So even though
the original graph
might have a lot of crossings,
when you go to a subgraph,
maybe there's a
better way to draw it.
But we just need an inequality
in the right direction.
So we are still OK.
And I claim that the
crossing number of G prime
is in expectation
at most p to be 4th
times the crossing number
of G. Because if you
keep the same drawing, then the
expected number of crossings
that are kept--
each crossing is kept if
all four of its end points
are kept.
So each crossing is kept with
probability p to the 4th.
So you can draw
it in expectation
with this many crossings.
Maybe it's much less.
Maybe there's a
better way to draw it,
but you have an inequality
going in the right direction.
Looking at that inequality
up there in yellow,
we find that the
crossing number of G
is at least p to the minus
2 E minus 3p to the minus 3.
And this is true for every
value of p between 0 and 1.
So now you pick a value of p
that works most in your favor.
And it turns out
you should do this
by setting these
two equalities to be
roughly equal to each other.
So setting p between 0 and
1 so that 4 times the--
basically, set these
two terms to be
roughly equal to each other.
And then we get that
this quantity here
is at least the
claimed quantity,
which is E cubed
over V squared up
to some constant factor, which
I don't really care about.
In order to set p, I have
to be a little bit careful
that p is between 0 and 1.
If you set p to be 1.2,
this whole argument
doesn't make any sense.
So this is OK.
So we know p is at most one
as long as E is at most 4p.
I mean, the 4 here is not
optimal, but if 4 were 2,
then it's not true.
So if E is 2V, you can
have a planar graph,
so you shouldn't have a lower
bound on the crossing number.
So this is the proof of the
crossing number inequality.
As I said, if you
have lots of edges,
then you must have
lots of crossings.
Any questions?
So let's use the crossing
number inequality
to prove a fundamental
result in incidence geometry.
Incidence geometry is
this area of discrete math
that concerns fairly
basic-sounding questions
about incidences between,
let's say, points and lines.
And here's an example.
So what's the maximum number
of incidences between endpoints
and end lines,
where by "incidence"
I mean if p-- so curly
p-- is a set of points,
and curly l is a set of lines,
then I write I of p and l
to be the number of pairs,
one point, one line, such
that the point lies on the line.
So I'm counting incidences
between points and lines.
You can view this in many ways.
You can view it as a bipartite
graph between points and lines,
and we're counting the number of
edges in this bipartite graph.
So I give you end
points, end lines.
What's the maximum
number of incidences?
It's not such an
obvious question.
So let's see how we can
approach this question.
But first, let me give
you some easy bounds.
So here's a trivial bound--
so here, I want to know if I
give you some number of points,
some number of lines, what's the
maximum number of incidences.
So a trivial bound is that
the number of incidences
is at most the product
between the number of points
and the number of lines.
One point, one line,
at most one incidence.
So that's pretty trivial.
We can do better.
So we can do better
because, well, you
see, let's use this following
fact, that every line--
so every pair of points
determine at most one line.
I have two points.
There's at most one line that
contains those two points.
Using this fact, we see
that the number of--
so let's count the number
of triples involving
two points and one line
such that both points lie
on the line.
So how big can this set be?
So let's try to count it
in two different ways.
On one hand, this
quantity is at most
the number of points squared,
because if I give you
two points, then they
determine this line--
so at most the number
of points squared.
But on the other hand, we see
that if I give you a line,
I just need to count
now the number of--
let me also require that
these two points are distinct.
So if I give you
a line, I now need
to count the number of pairs
of points on this line.
So I can enumerate over
lines and count line
by line how many pairs of
points are on that line.
So I get this
quantity over here.
On each line, I have
that contribution.
And now, using
Cauchy-Schwartz inequality,
we find that this
squared term is at least
the number of incidences
divided by the number of lines.
And the remaining minus
1 term contributes just
to the number of incidences.
So the first is by
Cauchy-Schwartz.
So putting these two
inequalities together,
we get some upper bound on
the number of incidences.
If you have to invert
this inequality,
you will get that the number
of incidences between points
and lines is upper bounded
by the number of points
times the number of
lines raised to power
1/2 plus the number of lines.
So that's what you get from
this inequality over here.
By considering
point-line duality--
so whenever you have this
kind of setup involving points
and lines, you can take
the projected duality
and transform the
configuration into--
lines into points and points
into lines, and the incidences
are preserved.
So I also have an inequality.
By duality-- I also
have an inequality
where I switch the roles
of points and lines.
So I is already the numbers.
I don't need to put an
extra absolute value sign.
So the number of
points and lines
is upper bounded by
the number of lines
times the square root
of a number of points
plus an extra term, just in
case there are very few lines.
So these are the bounds
that you have so far.
And the only thing that
we have used so far
is the fact that every two
points determine at most one
line, and every two lines
meet at at most one point.
So these are the
bounds that we get.
And in particular, for
end points and end lines,
we get the number
of incidences is--
they go off n to the 3/2.
This should remind you of
something we've done before.
So in the first
part of this course,
when we were looking at extremal
numbers, where did 3/2 come up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] like C4?
YUFEI ZHAO: C4, yeah.
So if you compare this quantity
to the extremal number of C4,
it's also n to the 3/2.
And in fact, the proof
is exactly the same.
All we're using here is that
the incidence graph is C4-free
So in fact, this is an
argument about C4-free graphs.
So this fact here, every two
points determine at most one
line, is saying that if you
look at the incidence graph,
there's no C4.
That's all we're using for now.
Any questions?
So is this the truth?
Now, back when we were
discussing the extremal number
for C4-free graphs, we
saw that, in fact, this
is the correct order.
And what was the
construction there?
So the construction also
came from incidences,
but incidences of
taking all lines
and points in the finite
field plain, Fq squared.
If you look at all the
lines and all the points
in a finite field
plain, then you
get the correct
lower bound for C4.
But now we are actually
working in the real plane,
so it turns out that the answer
is different when you're not
working the finite field.
We're going to be using the
topology of the real plane.
And we're going to come up
with a different answer.
So it turns out that
the truth for the number
of maximum number of
incidences in the plane,
for points and lines in the
real plane, is not exponent 3/2,
but turns out to be 4/3.
And this is a consequence
of an important result
in incidence geometry,
a fundamental result,
known as the
Szemeredi-Trotter theorem.
So the Szemeredi-Trotter
theorem says
that the number of incidences
between points and lines
is upper bounded by
this function where
you look at the number of points
times the number of lines,
and each raised to power 2/3
and plus some additional terms,
just in case there are many more
lines compared to points or way
more points compared to lines.
So that's the
Szemeredi-Trotter theorem.
And as a corollary, you see
that n points, n lines give you
at most n to the 4/3
incidences, in contrast
to the setting of the finite
field plain, where you can
get n to the 3/2 incidences.
So somehow, we have
to use the topology
of the real plane for this one.
And I want to show you a proof--
turns out not the
original proof,
but it's a proof that
uses the crossing number
inequality to prove
Szemeredi-Trotter theorem.
You see, in crossing
number inequality,
we are using the topology
of the real plane.
Where?
AUDIENCE: Euler's formula.
YUFEI ZHAO: Euler's
formula, right.
So the very beginning,
Euler's formula
has to do with the
topology of the real plane.
Now, this bound turns
out to be tight.
So let me give you
an example showing
that the 4/3 exponent is tight.
And the example
is, if you take p
to be this rectangular
grid of points,
and L to be a set
of lines-- so I'm
going to write the
lines by their equation,
where the slope is an
integer from 1 through k
and the y-intercept
is an integer from 1
through k squared.
And you see here
that every line in L
contains exactly k points
from P. So we got in total k
to the 4th incidences, which is
on the order of n to the 4/3.
So n to the 4/3 third
is the right answer.
Now let me show you how to
prove Szemeredi-Trotter theorem
from the crossing
number inequality.
It turns out to be a very
neat application that's
almost a direct consequence
once you set up the right graph.
And the idea is that we are
going to draw a graph based
on our incidence configuration.
So first, just to clean
things up a little bit,
let's get rid of lines in
L with 1 or 0 points in P.
So this operation doesn't
affect the bounds.
So you can check.
These lines don't contribute
much to the incidence bound,
and only contributes
to this plus L.
So you can get
rid of such lines.
So let's assume
that every line in L
contains at least
two points from P.
And let's draw a graph based
on this incidence structure.
So if I have--
so suppose these are
my points and lines.
I'll just draw a
graph where I keep
the points as the vertices,
and I put in an edge.
It's a finite edge that
connects two adjacent points
on the same line.
So I get some graph.
Let me make this graph
a bit more interesting.
So I get some graph.
And how many crossings, at
most, does this graph have?
So the number of
crossings of G is at most
the number of lines
squared, because a crossing
comes from two lines.
So here, you have a crossing.
A crossing comes from two lines.
Number of crossings is at
most number of lines squared.
On the other hand, we
can give a lower bound
to the number of crossings from
the crossing number inequality.
And to do that, I want to
estimate the number of edges.
And this is the reason why
I assume every line contains
at least two points from P,
because a line with now k
incidences gives
k minus 1 edges.
And if k is at least 2, then k
minus 1 is at least k over 2,
let's say.
I don't care about
constant factors.
So by crossing
number inequality,
the number of crossings
of G is at least
the number of edges cubed
over the number of vertices
squared, which is at least
the number of incidences
of this configuration cubed over
the number of points squared.
Actually, number of vertices
is the number of points.
And number of edges,
by this argument here,
is on the same order as
the number of incidences.
Putting these two facts
together, we see--
there was one extra hypothesis
in crossing number inequality.
Provided that this
hypothesis holds,
which is that the
number of incidences
is at least 8 times
the number of points,
so that the original
hypothesis holds.
So putting everything
together, and rearranging
all of these terms, and
using upper and lower bounds
on the crossing number, we find
that the number of incidences
is upper bounded by--
the main term you see is
just coming from these two,
but there are a few other terms
that we should put in, just
in case this
hypothesis is violated,
and also to take care of
this assumption over here,
so adding a couple of
linear terms corresponding
to the number of points
and the number of lines.
If this hypothesis is
violated, then the inequality
is still true.
So this proves the crossing
numbers inequality.
Any questions?
So we've done these
two very neat results.
The question is, what do they
have to do with the sum product
problem?
So I want to show you how
you can give some lower bound
on the sum product problem
using Szemeredi-Trotter theorem.
So it turns out that the sum
product problem is intimately
related to incidence geometry.
And the reason-- you'll see in
a second precisely why they're
related, but roughly speaking,
when you have addition
and multiplication,
they're are kind of
like taking slope
and y-intercept
of an equation of a line.
So there are two operations
that are involved.
So turns out, many incidence
geometry problems can be set up
and a way--
so many sum product
problems can be set up
in a way that involves
incidence geometry.
And a very short and clever
lower bound to the sum product
problem was proved by
Elekes in the late '90s.
So he showed the bound that if
you have a subset of finite,
subset of reals, then the sum
set size times the product set
size is at least A to the 5/2.
As a corollary, one of these
two must be fairly large.
The max of the sum set size
and the product set size
is at least a to the 5/4.
Let me show you the proof.
I'm going to construct a set
of points and a set of lines
based on the set A. And
the set of points in R2
is going to be pairs x comma y,
where the horizontal coordinate
lies in the sum set, A plus
A, and the vertical coordinate
lies in the product set, A
times A. And a set of lines
is going to be these lines--
y equals to a times x minus
a prime, where a and a prime
lie in A.
So these are some
points and some lines.
And I want to show you that
they must have many incidences.
So what are the incidences?
So note that the line y equals
to a times x minus a prime--
it contains the points
a prime plus b and ab,
which lies in P for all
b in A. You plug it in.
If you plug in a prime plus
b into here, you get ab.
And this point lies in P,
because the first coordinate
is the sum set.
The second coordinate
lies in the product set.
So each line in L
contains many incidences.
contains a incidents.
So this line, each line in
L contains a incidences.
Also, we can easily
compute the number of lines
and the number of points.
The number of points
is A plus A size
times the size of A times
A. And the number of lines
is just the size of A squared.
So by Szemeredi-Trotter, we find
that the number of incidences
is lower bounded by
noting this fact here.
We have many incidences.
So the number of lines, each
line contributes a incidences.
But we also have an
upper bound coming
from the
Szemeredi-Trotter theorem.
So plugging in the upper
bound, we find that you have--
so now I'm just
directly plugging
in the statement of
Szemeredi-Trotter.
The main term is the first term.
You should still check
the latter two terms,
but the main term
is the first term.
So plugging in the
values for P and L,
we find this is the case,
plus some additional terms,
which you can check are
dominated by the first term.
So let me just do
a big O over there.
Now you put left
and right together,
and we could obtain
some lower bound
on the product of the sizes
of the sum set and the product
set, thereby
yielding allocations.
So this is some lower bound
on the sum product problem.
And you see, we went through
the crossing number inequality
to prove Szemeredi-Trotter,
a basic result
in incidence geometry.
And viewing sum product as an
incidence geometry problem, one
can obtain this lower
bound over here.
Any questions?
I want to show you a different
proof that was found later,
that gives an improvement.
And there's a question,
can you do better than 5/4?
So it turns out that there was
a very nice result of Solymosi
sometime later that
gives you an improvement.
Solymosi proved
in 2009 that if A
is a subset of positive reals,
then the size of A times
A multiplied by the
size of A plus A squared
is at least size of
A to the 4th divided
by 4 ceiling log of the size
of A, where the log is base 2.
So don't worry about
the specific constants.
A being in the positive
reals is no big deal,
because you can always separate
A as positive and negative
and analyze each
part separately.
So as a corollary to
Solymosi's theorem,
we obtain that for A, a
subset of the reals, the sum
set and the product set,
at least one of them
must have size at
least A raised to 4/3
divided by 2 times log base 2
size of A raised to 1/3 third.
So basically, A to the 4/3 minus
little one in the exponent,
so better than before.
And this is a new bound.
I want to note that in
this formulation, where
we are looking at lower bounding
this quantity over here,
this is tied up to
logarithmic factors,
by considering A to be just
the interval from 1 to n.
If A is the interval
from 1 to n,
then the left-hand side, A
plus A, is around size n.
So you have n squared.
And A times A is
also, I mentioned,
around size n squared.
So this inequality
here is tight.
The consequence is not tight,
but the first inequality
is tight.
So in the remainder
of today's lecture,
I want to show you how to
prove Solymosi's lower bound.
And it has some
similarities to the one
that we've seen, because it also
looks at some geometric aspects
of the sum product problem.
But it doesn't use the exact
tools that we've seen earlier.
It does use some tools
that were related
to the lecture from Monday.
So last time, we
discussed this thing
called the "additive energy."
You can come up with a similar
notion for the multiplication
operation, so the
"multiplicative energy,"
which we'll denote by E sub,
with the multiplication symbol,
A. So the multiplicative energy
is like the additive energy,
except that instead
of doing addition,
we're going to do a
multiplication instead.
So one way to define it is
the number of quadruples such
that there exists some real
lambda such that a, comma,
b equals to lambda c, comma, d.
So basically the same
as additive energy,
except that we're using
multiplications instead.
By the Cauchy-Schwartz
inequality--
and this is a calculation
we saw last time, as well--
we see that if you have a
set with small product, then
it must have high
multiplicative energy.
So last time, we saw small
sum set implies high additive
energy.
Likewise, small product set
implies high multiplicative
energy.
In particular, the
multiplicative energy of A,
you can rewrite it as
sum over all elements
x in the product set of the
quantity, which tells you
the number of ways to
write x as a product,
this number squared and
then summed over all x.
By Cauchy-Schwartz, we find
that this quantity here is lower
bounded by the size of
A to the 4th divided
by the size of A times A. So
to prove Solymosi's theorem,
we are going to actually
prove a bound on the energy,
instead of proving
it on the set.
We're going to prove
it on the energy.
So it suffices to show that
the multiplicative energy is
at most 4 times the
sum set size times--
so let me divide the
energy by log of A.
So when you plug this
into this inequality,
it would imply that.
So it remains to
show this inequality
over here upper bounding
the multiplicative energy.
There's an important
idea that we're
going to use here, which is
also pretty common in analysis,
is that instead of considering
that energy sum here,
we're going to
consider a similar sum,
except we're going to chop up
the sum into pieces according
to how big the terms
are, so that we're only
looking at contributions
of comparable size.
And so this is called a
"dyadic decomposition."
The idea is that we can write
the multiplicative energy
similar to above, but
instead of summing over
x in the product set, let me
sum over s in the quotient set.
So you can interpret
what this quotient A is.
This is the set of all A divided
by B, where A and B are in A. A
is a set of positive
reals, so I don't need
to worry about division by 0.
So what remains, then,
is the intersection
of s times A and A squared.
Remember, s times A is scaling
each element of A by s.
So we have this
quantity over here.
So I want to break up the
sum into a bunch of smaller
sums, where I want to
break up the sum according
to how big the terms are,
so that inside each group,
all the terms are
roughly of the same size.
And easiest way to do
this is to chop them up
into groups where everything
inside the same collection
differs by at most
a factor of 2.
So that's why it's called
a dyadic decomposition,
going from 0 to--
the maximum possible
here is basically A.
So let's look at i going
from 0 to log base 2 of A.
So this is the number of bins.
And partition the
sum into sub-sums
where I'm looking at the
i-th sub-sum consisting
of contributions involving
terms with size between 2
to the i and 2 to the i plus 1.
Break up the sum according
to the sizes of the summands.
By pigeonhole principle,
one of these summands
must be somewhat large.
So by pigeonhole,
there exists a k
such that setting D to be the
s such that that corresponds
to the k-th term in the sum.
So one has that this sum coming
from just contributions from D
is at least--
so it's at least the
multiplicative energy
divided by the number of bins.
All of that many bins--
by pigeonhole, I
can find one bin
that's a pretty large
contribution to the sum.
And the right-hand side, we can
upper bound each term over here
by 2 to the 2k plus
2, and the number
of terms as the size of D. Let
me call the elements of D S1
through Sm, where S1 through Sm
are sorted in increasing order.
Now let me draw you a
picture of what's going on.
Let's consider for each element
of D, so for each i and m,
let's consider the line given
by the equation y equals to s
sub i times x.
Let me draw this
picture where I'm
looking at the
positive quadrant,
so I have a bunch of points
in the positive quadrant.
And specifically, I'm
interested in these points whose
coordinates, both coordinates
are elements of A.
And I want to consider
lines through points of A,
but I want to
consider lines where
it intersects this A cross A in
the desired number of points.
And we find those
set, and then let's
draw these lines over here,
where this line here, L1
has slope exactly S1,
and L2, L3, and so on.
I want to draw one more line,
which is somewhat auxiliary,
but just to make our
life a bit easier.
Finally, let's let L of m
plus 1 be the vertical line,
or rather be the
vertical ray, which
goes to the minimum
element of A above Lm.
So it's this line over here.
That's Lm plus 1.
So in A cross A, I
draw a bunch of lines.
So now all the lines--
so all these lines involve
some point of A and the origin,
but I don't draw all of them.
I draw a select set of them.
And what we said earlier says
that the number of lines,
the number of points on
each of these strong lines,
is roughly the same for
each of these lines.
Let's let capital L
sub j denote the set
of points in A cross A
that lie on the j-th line.
So that's L1, L2, and so on.
I claim that if you look
at two consecutive lines
and look at the sum set
of the points in A cross A
that intersect, you're
looking at two lines,
and you're adding up
points on those two lines.
So you form a grid.
So you end up forming this grid.
And the number of
points on this grid
is precisely the product
of these two point sets.
Moreover, the sets Lj
plus L sub j plus 1
are disjoint for different j.
And this is where we're using
the geometry of the plane here.
Because the sum of L1
and L2 lies in the span,
the sum of L2 and L3
in a different span,
so they cannot intersect.
So they lie in--
so since they span disjoint
regions, L1 plus L2 lies here,
L2 plus L3 lies
there, and so on.
But they're all disjoint.
Now let's put everything
that we know together.
Remember, the goal is to upper
bound the multiplicative energy
as a function of the sum set.
So in other words, we want
to lower bound the sum set.
So I want to show you that this
A plus A has a lot of elements.
There's a lot of sums.
And I have a bunch of disjoint
contributions to these sums.
So let's add up those disjoint
contributions to the sums.
You see that the size
of A plus A squared
is the same as the size of
the product set A plus A.
So this is Cartesian product.
Here is-- this is a
Cartesian product,
in other words, the grid
that is strong up there.
I add this product to itself.
So I should get
the same set here.
But how big is this sum set?
That grid, that lattice
grid added to itself,
how big should it be?
I want to lower bound
the number of sums.
And the key observation
is up there.
We can look at contributions
coming from distinct spans.
In particular, this sum
here, so this sum set here,
size is lower bounded by these
distinct Lj plus L j plus 1's.
I threw away a lot.
I only keep the lines on the
L's, and I only consider sums
between consecutive L's.
That should be a
lower bound to the sum
set of the grid with itself.
But you see, and here, we're
using these different--
for different j's, these
contributions are destroyed.
But by what we said up there,
Lj plus L j plus 1 is a grid.
So it has size Lj
times L j plus 1.
And the size of each Lj
is at least 2 to the k.
So the sum here is at
least m times 2 to the 2k.
But we saw over here that
the energy lower bounds
this 2 to the 2k.
So we have a lower bound that is
the multiplicative energy of A
divided by 4 times the log
base 2 of the size of A.
So don't worry so much
about the constant factors.
That's just the order of
magnitude that is important.
And that's it.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: How do you know that
the size of big L sub m plus 1?
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
The question is, what do we
know about the size of big L sub
m plus 1?
So that's a good point.
The easiest answer
is, if I don't
care about these
constant factors,
I don't need to worry about it.
You can think about what
is the number of points
on this line above that.
It's essentially the number of
elements of A above the biggest
element of s m, above s m.
It's a good question.
I think we don't need
to worry about it.
I'm being slightly sloppy here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: I think
the question is,
how do we know for j equals to
m that you have this bound over
here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
So yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So there
are some ways to do it.
You can notice that
the vertical line
has at least as many points
as the first slanted line.
So details that you can work on.
So this proves
Solymosi's theorem,
which gives you a lower bound
on the sum set and the product
set sizes and the
maximum of those two.
It's based on-- it's very short.
It's very clever.
It took a long time to find.
And it gave a bound
on the sum product
problem of 4/3 that
actually remained
stuck for a very
long time, until just
fairly recently there was
an improvement that gives--
so by Konyagin
and Shkredov where
they improved the Solymosi
bound from 4/3 to 4/3
plus some really
small constant c.
So it's some explicit constant.
I think right now-- so that's
being proved over time,
but right now, I think
c is around 1 over 1,000
or a few thousand.
So it's some small
but explicit constant.
It remains a major open
problem to improve this bound
and prove Erdos'
similarity conjecture,
that if you have n elements,
then one of the sums
or products must be
nearly quadratic in size.
And people generally believe
that that's the case.
Any questions?
So this concludes all the topics
I want to cover in this course.
So we went a long way.
And so the beginning
of this course,
we started with
extremal graph theory,
looking at the basic problem
of if you have a graph that
doesn't contain some
subgraph, triangle, C4, what's
the maximum number of edges.
In fact, that showed
up even today.
And then we went
down to other tools,
like Szemeredi's
regularity lemma
that allows us to deduce
important arithmetic
consequences, such
as Roth's theorem.
It's also an extremal
problem if you
have a set without a three-term
arithmetic progression,
how many elements can it have?
And so the important tool of
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
then later showed up
in many different ways
in this course,
especially the message
of Szemeredi's regularity
lemma, that when
you look at an object, it's
important to decompose it
into its structural component
and its pseudo-random
component.
So this dichotomy,
this interplay
between structure and
pseudo randomness,
is a key theme
throughout this course.
And it showed up in
some of the later topics
as well, when we discussed
spectral graph theory,
quasi-randomness,
graph limits, and also
in the later Fourier analytic
proof of Roth's theorem.
All of these proofs,
all of these techniques,
involve some kind of
interplay between structure
and pseudo-randomness.
In the past month
or, so we've been
looking at Freiman's
theorem, this key result
in additive combinatorics
concerning the structure
of sets under addition.
And there, we also saw many
different tools that came up,
and also connections I
mentioned a few lectures ago,
connections to really
important results
in geometry to group theory.
And it really
extends all around.
And a few takeaways
from this course--
one of them is that graph
theory, additive combinatorics,
they are not isolated subjects.
They're connected to a
lot within mathematics.
And that's one of the
goals I want to show you
in this course, is to
show these connections
throughout mathematics and
some to analysis, to geometry,
to topology.
And even simple
questions can lead
to really deep mathematics.
And some of them I try to
show you, try to hint at you,
or at least I mentioned
throughout this course.
And what we've seen so far is
just the tip of the iceberg.
And there is a lot of still
extremely exciting work
that's to be done.
And I've also tried to emphasize
many important open problems
that have yet to be
better understood.
And I expect in some future
iteration of this course,
some of these problems
will be resolved,
and I can show the next
generation of students
in your seats some new
techniques, new methods,
and new theorems.
And I expect that
will be the case.
This is a very exciting area.
And it's an area that is
very close to my heart.
It's something that I've been
thinking about since my PhD.
The bulk of my
research work revolves
around better understanding
connections between graph
theory, on one hand, and
additive combinatorics
on the other hand.
It's been really fun
teaching this course,
and happy to have
all of you here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]